in order to answer the age-old movie
myth that in space nobody can hear you
scream Ally Rachel and Canon 25 inches
of mercury at 51 dB cool
our waiting for their vacuum chamber to
hit 29.92 inches of mercury and it's
taking a while
I could call asleep patience my Padawan
I don't have patience it's one of my
talents the final few inches take the
longest because the pressure decreases
exponentially from the last reading 28
inches of mercury
until the vacuum is as close to perfect
as they can get
captain raspberry has ascended from the
peak of Everest to approximately 18
miles above sea level it's as close to
space as he's ever gonna get so this is
it
is his scream inaudible all right we're
at a full vacuum for 30 inches of
mercury that is 49 decibel still seems
kind of loud
well the whoopee cushion isn't moving
anymore and there's no air in the
chamber the Sun has to be coming from
somewhere yeah that's weird isn't it you
know what it is it's the motor I can
feel it vibrating and hitching under my
fingers
our microphone is picking up more than
just to scream there are two spikes the
sound of the scream and the sound of the
motor and when we're at a full vacuum
the center of the scream goes away yep
there is no scream in the vacuum chamber
the only noise picked up by the mic is
the vibration of the motor where it's
making contact with the Chamber's wall
there's definitely not a scream of that
chamber No
so have we answered it good question
captain raspberry has now taken his
maiden voyage into space he was able to
continue screaming until we had pulled
the full vacuum and then his vocal cords
are not moving there was no air in the
system and it was pretty amazing
it's a pretty good test in my opinion
myth confirmed right no air equals no
scream well not so fast
teen scream has one last scenario they
want to test one last breath
this is our last breath this is as if
you're thrust out of the airlock and
only have what air you are able to save
in your lungs one our lung is played by
this bicycle inner tube once filled with
air and under a full vacuum the breath
will be released I got it send that to
the pile that's terrifying
it should answer the question whether in
space no one can hear you scream team
scream has already proven that with no
medium to carry sound like a new
instrument there is no sound you am all
right let's vacuum this puppy up you're
ready to turn this on the previous test
removed all the air from the system
all right we're going on to ten inches
of mercury and the result was as
expected but this time the unlucky
astronaut Adam looks very happy floating
around his face is jettisoned into space
while holding one last lung full of air
are we there yet
amen don't try that I will turn this car
right around we're almost there
to simulate that the team will bring the
chamber to a vacuum with that one last
breath intact and then let him scream
we are at 29 and a half this is perfect
my experimental astronaut is holding his
last breath Ali you want to call it in
yeah are you ready I'm ready
recording all right this is last breath
and space atom whoopee cushion test in
three two let's go check it out if Adams
last breath was audible
it was so faint the team missed it but
the vibration of the whoopee cushion
looked promising why did the mic pick up
all right Kenan what do you get
that's a sound that actually sounds like
a fart like at last dying fart in space
that's a result well done thank you
standing how is it possible to hear my
last dying scream inside this vacuum
chamber well quite simply because the
air being exhaled by my lungs is
providing a medium for that sound to
travel to the outside of the chamber oh
but wait a minute I hear you complaining
that's not accurate to the vacuum of
space and I would agree except under
this one specific case that is imagine
you're in a space with holding on to
someone who isn't and they exhaled their
last breath to scream at you I would
submit that their breath would carry
maybe just across a foot of space the
sound of their scream into your helmet
that's a result I will stand behind
alright guys the myth you have been
testing is that in space no one can hear
you scream I don't know why I'm talking
like that busted plausible or confirmed
we found the exception that as long as
they're within a foot of the person
who's screaming you can still hear them
that would mean it's busted busted
busted